what's the difference to you
between you see patients between sort of
rigorous
um
psychoanalysis i don't know if you
consider where you like talk therapy and
psychoanalysis are they neighbors are
they overlapping their their neighbors
uh psychoanalysis is
it's um
they're relatively it's not nearly done
as much as the talk therapy like the
cognitive behavioral therapy i mentioned
the the psychoanalysis is is a little
more niche now and partly because it's
it's not
data isn't um
in terms of actual treatment of actual
therapeutic effects
data not as supportive as for cognitive
behavioral therapy
but it's still interesting as for
insight people a lot of people still do
it to gain insight into themselves
and in general it's a good sort of
conversation starter those methods you
know they're good for
getting things out you know
we don't focus on dreams uh typically
these days in psychiatry but they're
great conversation starters they're
great ways to get things out if people
have
uh and and so we like to use those
methods just to get the the ball rolling
sometimes get people to open up a little
bit but the actual treatment
that tends not to involve these
psychoanalytic approaches where you
are really probing uh the unconscious
mind and its manifestation through
through dreams
uh for example as as the as the goal
that's not the goal modern talk therapy
we're really focusing on treatment how
to get people to feel better see i use
that as a conversation opener to the
freudian
thing where i try to delve at a bar
of the deep sexual desires in a person's
subconscious and i find that opens up
possibilities very quickly now um
what's i mean this is a silly sounding
question but what's the difference
between cognitive behavioral therapy
and conversation
so
um because i personally as a fan of
conversations as a fan of just i like
listening to podcasts
um versus like audiobook i like both but
they're very different and i like
conversation i like um it makes me
personally very anxious so i like to be
the listener
uh like like a third wheel like
overhearing a conversation kind of thing
but
it's a really powerful method for humans
to explore each other's mind just raw
conversation so
do you think
it can be more productive to be very
systematic about it or is conversation
itself the art form of
of helping each other understanding each
other and helping each other
there are forms of talk therapy that are
essentially conversational or they much
more approach pure conversation there's
uh there are there's a befriending
therapy there's interpersonal therapy
these are these are approaches that are
purely talk therapy
but they're
not as structured as cognitive
behavioral therapy cognitive behavioral
therapy as is there are manuals there
are guidelines you can almost go through
it in a very cookbooky way there's
there's homework that you get done so
it's
in its fullest form
it's very different from these more
conversational strategies but what's
interesting is sometimes people compare
them and so you'll see
almost like randomized controlled
studies
comparing cognitive behavioral therapy
with interpersonal therapy for example
and they both can work and actually in
some studies they look uh comparable
so there's
to your point
conversation and insights that come from
conversation if done well if done
artfully
can be
as powerful
you